[Música]
Qué pasa después de la muerte Hay un
paraíso donde descansar un tormento
eterno un Renacimiento O tal vez solo la
nada bueno un emperador chino pensó que
independientemente de lo que hubiera en
el más allá Más vale llevarse un
ejército en 1974 unos agricultores que
acababan un pozo cerca de un pequeño
pueblo tropezaron con uno de los más
importantes hallazgos arqueológicos
grandes cámaras subterráneas que
rodeaban la tumba de aquel emperador con
más de ocho mil soldados de terracota de
tamaño natural listos para la batalla la
historia empieza con que llegó al poder
como rey del estado de quien a los 13
años en el 246 antes de Cristo
ambicioso y despiadado se convertiría en
kimchi el primer emperador de China
después de unir sus siete reinos en
su reinado duró 36 años y vio muchos
logros históricos incluido un sistema
Universal de pesas y medidas un solo
alfabeto estandarizado para toda China y
una barrera defensiva que más tarde se
conoció como la Gran Muralla
quizás
dedicó tanto esfuerzo a asegurar su
legado porque estaba obsesionado con su
mortalidad
pasó sus últimos años empleando
alquimistas y llevando a cabo
expediciones en busca del elixir de la
vida para alcanzar la inmortalidad ya en
el primer año de su reinado empezó la
construcción de una enorme necrópolis
subterránea llena de monumentos
artefactos y un ejército que lo
acompañara en la otra vida donde
continuaría su gobierno este magnífico
ejército sigue en pie en formación de
batalla precisa y se divide en varias
fosas una contiene un cuerpo principal
de 6000 soldados donde cada uno pesa
varios cientos de kilos una segunda fosa
cuenta con más de 130 carros de guerra y
más de 600 caballos y la tercera alberga
a los altos mandos una cuarta fosa vacía
sugiere que el proyecto no se terminó
antes de su muerte
además las cámaras cercanas contienen
estatuas de músicos y acróbatas
trabajadores y funcionarios del gobierno
y varios animales lo que indica que el
emperador Kim tenía más planes para el
más allá que solo librar guerras todas
las estatuillas están esculpidas en
terracota un tipo de arcilla de color
marrón rojizo para construir las varios
talleres y más de 720,000 trabajadores
fueron empleados por el emperador
incluidos grupos de artesanos que
moldearon cada parte del cuerpo por
separado para construir estatuas
individuales que correspondían a los
verdaderos Guerreros del ejército del
emperador están hechos según sus rangos
y cuentan con diferentes armas y
uniformes peinados y expresiones
distintas e incluso orejas únicas cada
Guerrero fue pintado en colores
brillantes pero su exposición al aire
hizo que la pintura se secara cayera y
dejara al descubierto la terracota es
por esta misma razón que otra cámara a
menos de dos kilómetros de distancia no
excavado Esta es la tumba real de kimchi
que se dice que contiene Palacios
piedras preciosas y artefactos e incluso
ríos de mercurio que fluyen a través de
montañas de bronce pero hasta que no se
encuentre una manera de excavarla sin
dañar los tesoros que hay dentro la
tumba permanecerá sellada el emperador
quien no fue el único que preparó su
morada final las tumbas egipcias
antiguas tienen réplicas que representan
la otra vida ideal los muertos de la era
kofón en Japón fueron enterrados con
esculturas de caballos y casas y las
tumbas de la isla de llana en México
tiene estatuillas de cerámica el
emperador King eligió tener sirvientes y
soldados construidos para este fin en
lugar de sacrificar a los vivos para que
le acompañaran como las prácticas que
había en Egipto África occidental
anatolia partes de América del Norte e
incluso en China durante las dinastías
anteriores
Y hoy la gente viaja desde todo el mundo
para ver a estos estoicos soldados que
esperan en silencio sus órdenes de
batalla
otro monumento icónico que aún captura
la imaginación del público es la torre
inclinada de Pisa en Italia Por qué se
inclina exactamente y Alguna vez se
caerá obtenga más información sobre la
creación y la historia de la Torre con
este video